most triple-a titles these days are
pretty predictable you have the hero the
villain the polite dialog choice the
rude dialogue choice the bad guys the
good guys and all the meaningless
choices along the way if you're watching
my videos then you should already know
the darksouls breaks the mold most games
either have one cannon ending or allow
you to choose from a selection of moral
minefield endings at the end of the game
Dark Souls is the latter but the endings
are ambiguous as hell the more you learn
about the game the more confusing the
endings become most games give you
closure but both Dark Souls endings
probably leave you wondering what would
happen next what consequence would my
choice have in the game world the first
ending will analyze is the length of
fire ending you sacrifice your body and
soul as fuel for the first flame which
keeps the gods in power we'll call this
the light ending your other choice is
letting the flame die out allowing you
to become the Dark Lord and ushering in
the age of man let's call this the dark
ending now this video assumes you have
some idea of what's going on in the Dark
Souls universe if you don't have a Dark
Souls lore in a minute video you could
watch or you could brush up on the
fundamentals presented by epic named
brush to properly understand the endings
you must understand what makes them
significant in the beginning the four
Lord Souls were found within the first
flame Gwyn obtained the light soul and
ushered in an age of fire based around
that first flame this age of fire meant
that the gods and the Lords were in
control of the world ruling over
humanity they lit bonfires from the
first flame and shepherded the humans
but where did the humans come from well
it's my theory that humanity is spawned
from the fragments of the dark soul as
humanity split and grew and split and
grew the dark began to overcome the
light this concept of disparity plays a
huge role in the game
as the first flame faded the light faded
and as the light faded the power of Gwyn
and the age of fire faded as the God
started to lose their power they began
to recognize the threat that humanity
could pose it seems the gods couldn't
decide what to make of humanity in the
dialogues of Kirin and Gough
we see some of this uncertainty if you
aid them they decide that humans aren't
so bad after all but if you slide them
then they treat you with that built-up
resentment shoo shoo shoo Yamamoto the
flame continues to fade the gods abandon
Anna Londo and the remaining gods use
illusions to preserve their power Gwyn
older of the light soul goes to the kiln
of the first flame and offers himself as
fuel he sacrifices himself to let the
flame burn a little longer this buys the
gods a bit more time to find a solution
to their problem you have that solution
by linking the fire you become the fuel
for the first flame with you in Gwynn's
place the age of fire can continue but
what makes you so special
well characters are very powerful Undead
if they can make it all the way to Gwyn
and it follows that the more powerful
you are the longer you will burn it
could be that this is why frampt is
trying to push undead towards Gwyn he's
trying to find the one who will burn the
longest
so by burning in grins place you have to
ask yourself what purpose it serves
you're preserving the reign of the gods
and rising to the needs of a dying
hierarchy it's not even a temporary
solution Gwyn was powerful enough to
take out the immortal dragons and even
he became asked by the end so while you
could see linking the flame as a
selfless act it's hard to imagine that
you're doing it for any greater purpose
indeed if you linked the flame you are
rising to the needs of people who could
simply be using you so is this the good
ending at first glance it seems like it
most players go through the game only
meeting the serpent frampt who promises
that linking the flame will undo the
curse of the undead he talks of fate and
gives you purpose so at first I thought
this was the right thing to do I didn't
know that Anna Wanda and Guinevere were
illusions I didn't know I was being used
and I thought I was being selfless but
then I heard what calf had to say he
says that after the advent of fire the
ancient Lords found three souls but your
progenitor found the Dark Soul and
waited for fire to subside he says that
with the fading flame comes the age of
man he paints Gwyn as a God who resisted
the course of nature and says that you
are being manipulated by frampt to keep
Gwynn's age of fire going
by killing Gwyn and walking away from
the first flame Kath promises that the
dark will finally come and with it the
age of man will begin at first I thought
that calf's hidden dialog was the truth
it makes sense when you realize that
frampt is manipulating you you feel like
you should believe everything calf has
to say it seems like Qarth is telling
the whole truth but is he telling the
whole truth is the darkness really a
place where humans can thrive humans are
born from the dark soul that much is
true the black humanity sprite is proof
of that but when we journey back to see
what happened in all Aseel we realize
how dangerous the dark is to humans all
the silvers once a human city overrun by
the dark these are its residents and
this is the fate of the humans who come
into contact with the dark this is the
age of man that car promises one serpent
tells you lies and the other tells you
truth both of them are manipulating you
if you link the fire you are sacrificing
yourself so that frampt and gwyndolin
can rule
with the illusion of power in Anor Londo
if you let the flame fade the age of
dark will come but is this a place where
humans thrive no will the seal is proof
of that in the end it doesn't matter
what you do if you link the flame you're
just delaying the inevitable if you let
the flame fade the darkness comes a
little sooner with you at the helm the
one can an ending to dark souls is in
the prologue one day the flame will fade
and only dark will remain so instead of
choosing an ending just go and live with
Priscilla or something
you
you